cars they're pretty nifty but wouldn't
it be great if you didn't have to drive
them so people have begun developing
driverless cars both for convenience and
safety human error plays a part in over
90 percent of crashes now new research
shows there could be another big plus
driverless taxis could be great news for
the environment driverless taxis are
economical they can be tailored to your
ride if only one person needs a lift
using the smaller taxi with safe space
and energy driverless taxis traveled
further privately owned cars spend most
of the day just sitting about but
driverless taxis can keep zipping around
for most of the day and night so they
end up traveling further each day than
normal cars and for cars that travel
further it makes sense to be electric
that's because electricity is cheaper
per mile than petrol producing
electricity is also better for the
environment than burning petrol although
electricity mostly comes from fossil
fuels right now power supplies are
becoming greener all the time all these
benefits really add up compared to a
normal car today
a driverless taxi in 2030 could reduce
emissions per mile by up to 94 percent
even if we're all driving hybrids in
2013 using driverless taxis instead
could still reduce our emissions but
there's a catch people what's unclear in
these calculations is how people will
use these taxis human behavior could
undo a lot of these benefits for example
people might not want to travel in an
economical little taxi instead they
might order a bigger vehicle for added
comfort and style
and that's if we get the system up and
running in the first place some experts
think we won't manage that before the
2030s people might not trust driverless
vehicles there might be too much red
tape or the technology might just be too
difficult to develop but if driverless
taxis do make it onto our roads they
could hugely reduce emissions and help
protect the environment plus it shall
give us more time to play with Lego